[Applause]
to present the best award for best
actress the Academy is called upon the
gentleman who won his Oscar last year
for his performance and Lully's of the
field but how could he miss he had all
those men spraying for this year he was
on his own but he's here anyway as a
presenter mr. Sidney Poitier
Bob when I was here last year I was so
excited
could you tell me did I say thank you
well I don't know Sydney I didn't do the
show last year didn't you watch it a
show without me surely you jest the
nominees for Best Performance by an
actress are Julie Andrews and Mary
Poppins and Bancroft in the pumpkin
eater Sophia Loren in marriage
italian-style
Debbie Reynolds in the Unsinkable Molly
Brown
Tim Stanley in seance on a wet afternoon
the winner is
Julie Andrew
oh it's lovely I know you Americans are
famous to your hospitality but this is
really ridiculous I have so many thank
yous I only know where to start and that
was mr. Walt Disney and naturally he has
the larger thank you of all I wouldn't
know where to stop
I would somehow like to try and convey
my really deep gratitude and and wealth
gratefulness and work have to say that a
man for being made to feel so really
welcome in this country thank you very
much